>>Dave Sparks: All right. Good afternoon.
Welcome. I am really happy to have everyone
here.
My name is Dave Sparks, and I am the technical
lead on the Android media framework.
And I am going to give you a talk this afternoon
about advanced audio techniques and Android,
and also give you some highlights about the
Froyo release that we just announced today.
And then talk a little bit about roadmap.
So if you are going to follow along in Wave,
here is the URL. And I'll leave this slide
up for a little bit so you have a chance to
type it in if you want to follow along there.
So a few questions. How many people here are
active Android developers?
So you have written an application. Okay.
How many people actually have an application
up in Market?
Wow, that's a pretty good showing. Not bad.
And anybody have more than one?
All right.
A few hard-core developers.
Everybody get a chance to see the Android
keynote this morning?
Not many people?
Okay. Well, one of the exciting things we
announced this morning was the Google TV stuff.
It's pretty exciting, I think.
So did everybody hear about Google TV? Yeah.
Anybody interested in developing for Google
TV as well?
>>> Yes.
>>Dave Sparks: All right. Okay.
So I am just trying to get a feeling for where
people are in terms of development and excitement
about Android.
So we will move on. Hopefully you have had
a chance to get that URL.
So the agenda today, I am going to talk about
native audio signal processing in Android.
There's been a lot of interest in doing something
more than manipulating bytes in Java code,
so I will give you some sample code snippets
that you can use to get started.
We'll talk a little bit about resource and
power management. I revisit this every time
I do talks or anytime I talk to developers
about battery power usage and resource management
is really critical on these battery powered
devices, obviously. So I will talk a little
bit about that.
As I mentioned earlier I am going to talk
about some of the new stuff we have thrown
into Froyo. We think some of it is pretty
exciting.
And finally, we will talk a little bit about
the roadmap for future releases and some of
the stuff we are working on right now. And
then hopefully we will have at least a few
minutes at the end for Q&A.
We are going to try to catch up a little bit.
I guess the keynote ran late this morning
and we are kind of behind on the schedule.
So I will try to go fast and not lose too
many people.
So we'll start with talking about native audio
signal processing on Android.
So everything we do in Android right now,
basically you are doing through some sort
of Java interface. So I will start with an
overview of the audiotrack interface in Android
so you have a sense of how you connect into
things. So we will look at Java code first.
So the audiotrack interface is basically a
raw PCM interface. You give it raw 16 bit
or eight bit audio and it gets mixed in through
an audio subsystem we call audio flinger.
It does whatever sample rate conversion it
needs to get to the sample output of the device.
And then you can do mixing, left/right balance,
things like that in the API.
So it basically gives you a way to send your
application's audio directly to an output.
So you can generate that, you can take a Wave
file and output it. Whatever you want to do
with the audio.
We have people doing things like soundboards
and synthesizers and things like that using
this interface.
It allows you to do both streaming and static
buffers. So a streaming buffer meaning you
are generating the audio on the fly, maybe
you are streaming it over a network connection
or you are reading out of a file, but you
have a small buffer. You fill the buffer,
and there's a read pointer and a write pointer,
and the write pointer needs to stay ahead
of the read pointer, and you just loop back.
So that's the streaming mode.
There's also a static mode where you can fill
it up with typically a small sound that you
are going to play a lot. An example might
be a prompt, a beep something or a gunshot
in a game.
It's actually very low overhead because that
data gets buffered up in the audio flinger
service, and you don't actually have data
flowing across from the application side to
the server side.
You can set call backs to refill the buffer.
So in the case where you are doing streaming,
you can set a call back say halfway through
the buffer. That prompts you to go generate
new audio for the part of the buffer that
just emptied. So it uses a poll model that
way.
You can also retrieve the play position, so
if you are trying to do some long stream,
if you want to do synchronization in a game
or something like that, you can find out where
the play pointer is at any particular time,
and it takes into account the latency in the
audio path.
Now, obviously, this is really useful for
games, or if you are doing streaming audio.
Any kind of thing where you are generating
audio on the fly.
So here is some sample code using the Java
interface and then we will dive a little deeper
into this and see how we do it in native code.
So if you look up here, we have this class
called audiotrack sample. And it implements
runnable so it's going to spinoff a thread
that's generating audio.
And we have declared a few variables here.
End buffer size is the size of the buffer
in samples. In this case it's 8,000, which
translates to roughly about 180 milliseconds
of audio, but you choose whatever you want.
There are some constraints on that. We need
to buffer enough audio that we are not running
out of data and having audio breakup, so you
may need to experiment with that depending
on your application.
Mtrack is the audio track object itself, and
then mbuffer is the audio sample buffer. And
then msample is a state variable we will talk
about a later which we use for generating
audio. In the next slide you'll see where
that comes into play.
We start off by initializing the buffer and
we create an audio track. In this case it's
a music stream, so in Android we have this
concept of different stream types, and each
of those stream types has their own individual
volume control. So if you are doing a game
or something that's typically a foreground
application, you probably want to use the
music stream. Ring tones and notifications
are controlled by a different stream.
So we have -- basically you can set different
audio levels for different types of streams.
And in this case it's a mono output so we
are just generating one channel. The audio
mixer will automatically reflect that to both
left and right channels if it's a stereo output.
And then the buffer size is specified in bytes.
So that's where we are multiplying the buffer
size by two when you look at that. M buffer
size times two is because audiotrack wants
the buffer size in bytes.
And we want to operate in stream mode because
we are going to be generating this audio on
the fly.
And then the run function here, next part
of the slide here, we start playing the track,
basically arms the track to start playing.
And as soon as you have buffered enough audio,
it will start output to go the audio output
device. And then we have a loop to generate
the audio and write it to the audio track.
So those are the next two lines there.
Obviously if were you doing a real application,
would you need something a little bit more
than that because you probably would want
to stop at some point. I haven't implemented
that code. It wouldn't all fit on the slide
but I think you get the idea.
So moving on, this is the code that actually
is going to generate a tone. And I used something
really simple here. We are just generating
a sawtooth Wave, that's just basically a linear
ramp. It sounds like a fat synthesizer sound.
We are not -- At this rate, by adding 600
we are going to wrap around, and we generate
roughly 400 hertz sawtooth. So it's filling
the buffer with some really simple audio.
So that's basically how the Java interface
works.
Now, if you want to use native code, first
thing is you need to download the Android
NDK. So you have the Android SDK. You are
going to download the NDK as well.
You are going to build a Java application.
You start with a Java app. And you are going
to add the native code to it as a library.
So once you have your Java app built, like
let's say this one, you create a native library,
and that really just involves writing some
source code. You can take a sample MIG file
from the NDK and use that to build your library.
And the library will have basically implementations
of Java methods that are declared in the Java
object.
And so that's basically -- we add a native
method to a Java class and we can call the
native code from Java.
And then in the Java class itself, at some
point you need to load the native library
to allow the VM to link the methods that you
have declared in the Java class to the actual
native code.
And then you just call your native methods
from Java just like you would anything else.
So we'll take a look at some actual native
code here.
So this is -- going back to our Java sample,
this is the Java code again. This is actually
the same as the first slide. Nothing has changed
here. We are doing all the same things.
All the magic happens on the next page, which
is where we were doing the generate tone stuff
before.
So now if you look at it, we have this static
declaration here, system load library, and
that actually loads a .SO file called generate
underscore tone.so. So that's where the native
code is getting written. So when you are doing
your native code, in particular this example
I probably would have a generate tone.c or
C++ file, and in that I would have my native
code, I would build it, link it, and I would
end up with an SO, and this is how it gets
loaded. So as soon as this class gets loaded
in your application, the VM is going to go
look for that library, load it, and then it
will do the links from the Java code to the
native code for you.
And that all happens automatically.
And then in this next section, we have the
public native int generate tone.
So basically this is the same call signature
we had for the Java object. We just added
a native thing to it and that tells the Java
byte code generator to look for an external
symbol, which is this native code.
And then here we're moving on to the actual
native code. So this is in C++. And you are
going to have a function here, generate tone,
and it needs to have the package signature
and class signature that you declared in your
Java class.
So going back to the Java class, it was, you
know, com.example.JNI sample is the class,
and generate tone is the method. So this is
how the linker finds the method and links
it up.
This works if you have a single call signature.
So if I only have one generate tone, it will
be able to find it that way.
If you have multiple -- and if you have got
an overloaded method, then you are going to
need to do something more sophisticated than
that which gives it the actual call signatures
with at parameters.
SO but for a simple thing like this, this
is the easiest way to do it. You just have
one method and overloading it is really simple
to get this to work.
So just some simple stuff.
You typically, when you are writing native
code, you want to do some sanity checking
on the parameters you are getting from Java.
So -- because it's easy to end up with a crash
in native code as opposed to in Java where
you get a stack trace.
If it happens in native code, you are not
going to get the nice stack trace. And if
you remember this morning, if you were at
the keynote we have this new reporting code
in Market that allows you to get stack traces
if you have a Java crash, where you are not
going to get those nice traces if it happens
in native code. So make sure your native code
is clean.
So here we are just checking to make sure
that we are getting a reasonable volume for
size. And the next line we call get primitive
array critical, and we are passing in the
buffer pointer, basically the Java buffer
object. And we get back a C short star pointer.
So that's the actual pointer to the buffer
data that Java would see.
So it basically gives us the hooks we need
to go talk -- you know, access that buffer
from C code.
One critical thing here, basically this is
pinning that array in memory, so it can't
be GC'd.
During a GC, it could potentially move around,
so this is basically telling the VM don't
move that code -- that object. I am doing
something with it.
And of course at the end of that, you need
to make sure you release it.
So now that we have a valid pointer to the
buffer and we're going to check that, obviously,
make sure that we actually get a valid pointer
back, because it's possible that object might
have been -- might not be a valid Java object.
So doing another check there to make sure
Pdata is actually not null.
Then we basically have implemented that code
to fill the buffer with audio in C here.
So it's pretty much the same algorithm. We
start with a sample of zero, fill it up, wrap
the -- have the value advance by 600 each
time, and that gives us, again, roughly a
400 hertz tone.
And at the end there, the release primitive
critical array, basically that -- array critical,
unpins that memory and allows a GC to happen
if necessary later on.
So it's a really simple way to take advantage
of native C processing.
So this is a way, if you wanted do something
sophisticated like maybe a synthesize arrangement
or your own mixer, audio mixer, or do some
signal processing in C, could you hook into
the existing audio track class to do that.
So there's one little difference in this code
from what we had in the Java code.
In the Java code, that sawtooth generator,
we were actually saving the state of the sawtooth
generator at the end of each generate tone
in a variable called Msample.
In the C code I just showed you, I wasn't
doing that. We'd actually end up with discontinuity
in the signal.
So the reason I didn't include that is it
wouldn't -- if I put that on one slide, you
wouldn't be able to read it, so I had broken
it up into a couple of pieces.
Now we are going to see how from C code you
can access other Java objects.
So going back to the same code, I have kind
of pulled out some stuff -- the code-to-pin,
the data array and stuff like that -- and
I am focusing right now on that one little
section of code that actually generates the
tone.
So at the beginning of this function, if you
look at the top you see a static there which
is Msample field. This is an index into the
-- it basically gives us a way to get at
the Java objects from the Java -- Java members
from the Java object itself.
So at the beginning of this function, we check
to see if that's zero. So if it was static
and initialized to zero, the first time you
call this function it's going to be zero.
And then what we do is we look up the class
through the Java environment.
So in the call of the signature of this function,
we get the Java VM environment, and we also
get the object.
So we're going to use the Java VM to call
find class, and we know the name of that package,
so we are going to go look for that class,
and we get back a field ID for the class itself.
And assuming we actually find that class,
and it's hard to believe that might fail but,
you know, here is the sanity check just in
case. We then do a lookup with get field ID
for the member called Msample.
So in Java, we call -- this is an int member
of the Java class.
So we're looking it up and the S tells it
that it's a short type. So we are looking
for a variable Msample, type short, that's
in the class com.example.JNI sample.JNI sample.
And it should return back a value that's not
zero. And that's the handle you need to get
at the object within the member of that class
of that particular object.
So I have commented out the code there that
actually does the pinning the data buffer.
And instead we're going to focus on the actual
tone generator.
So the first thing we do is we call get short
field, and we are passing in THIZ which is
the pointer to the Java object we got and
the call to this native function. And we are
passing M sample field which is the index
in the class to that member within the Java
object.
And we get back the value of that object.
So now we are able to retrieve state from
the Java side, and then in the function, we
use that to generate the tone.
So now we can start with the last sample and
we continue generating from where we were.
This little loop is the same as it was before.
Then at the end, we are going to save that
value back into the Java object itself.
So set short field, we pass the dot Java object
pointer, M sample field which is the field
we want to set and the actual value that we
want to set it to.
And then what that will do is now reflect
that value up into Java.
So this allows you to store state information
in native code in the Java object itself,
instead of having to keep a separate set of
-- you know, a structure or something like
that, to store that code.
If you are just doing a few variables, this
is probably the way you want to do it.
The other option you can do is you can store
a pointer. There are some -- Since Java doesn't
have a native pointer type, there's some pitfalls
to that. At some point, if we change to larger
64-bit pointers, for example, if we ever had
a device that had that, you could run into
problems. But we do a lot of this stuff in
the platform code where we will store a pointer
to a bunch of data, because there is a fairly
good cost to looking up the value of the Java
object through the VM.
So if you have a lot of state information,
you might want to consider saving that as
a C structure or something. So you allocate
it when the object is created, and you de-allocate
it when it's released.
It's a little trickier to get that right because
you have to do all the correct work to make
sure you are not leaking memory.
So that's kind of the quick take-through of
the native signal processing.
I am going to just really quickly run through
the power and resource stuff.
If you have seen me before, I say this every
time. Make sure you call release on media
objects. Almost every object we in the media
framework has a release call. The reason for
the release call is if you don't call release,
you have to wait for a GC to actually call
the finalizer, and that's when the resources
are de-allocated.
Typically, for example, let's say you have
got a media player. There's very likely a
hardware CODEC that's been instantiated in
the media server to decode video or decode
audio. And as long as you are holding that
media player object in your Java application,
there are resources in the media server that
are being consumed. That includes, you know,
potentially battery power, DSP, et cetera,
et cetera.
So you want to make sure you clean those up
quickly.
And if you wait for a GC, it may be five,
ten seconds, who knows, before the GC happens.
Just depends on how much memory pressure there
is.
So the release forces it to immediately do
a finalize on any of the native resources
that have been allocated. So it's really critical
for battery power and also for interoperability.
You don't want to be holding onto an object
that potentially another application might
want to use or even another activity in your
own application.
And as I say, this powers down unneeded hardware.
In many cases, for example, if we have a hardware
CODEC, we are powering up a DSP that's consuming
maybe 40 or 50 milliamps more than the device
consumes without the DSP turned on and that
can have a significant impact upon battery
life over the long run.
And like I say, it's nice to cooperate with
other applications. If you are getting switched
out, another application is coming up and
it needs that same resource, it may not be
able to get it. So making sure you call release
during the on-pause, make sure that other
applications can get access to it.
Another critical thing is making sure that
you are actually calling from on pause and
not from on destroy.
There are circumstances where you may not
immediately get a call to your on destroy
in your activity, and in that case, a good
example is from the home screen -- if you
are -- sorry. If you have an application running
and somebody hits the home button, you typically
don't get -- immediately get an on destroy.
And so you need to take that into consideration.
You really should do it on on-pause.
So kind of moving quickly on to the next segment,
we're going to talk about what's new in Froyo.
We have a new API we call audio focus, basically,
audio focus and transport control API.
I will get into this a little bit later with
some sample code.
We've made some improvements to soundpool,
some things that people have requested.
We've also added a new -- some improvements
and a way to route audio specifically in an
application, this is to accommodate things
like voice mail.
And I'll go over that a little bit later.
And then we have also made some improvements
to the camera.
So there you go.
So Audio Focus and transport APIs.
If you've done any development on Android
or have done anything, particularly with audio,
there's been a lot of problems with conflicts
between applications, particularly if you
have an application that's playing in the
background and, you know, streaming audio
or music playing or method casts or whatever.
There were some things we did early on that
were probably not the best decisions, and
so we went back and looked at that and said,
how can we improve the situation with cooperating
between applications that want to play audio.
This particularly became a little distressing
when we launched the navigation, turn-by-turn
navigation.
Because here's an application that wants to
periodically inject voice prompts so you can,
you know, hear -- you know, find out where
you're going.
You're in the car.
But if you're listening to a podcast, having
the voice prompts over the top of a podcast
is really, really distracting.
So we wanted to make sure we could handle
that use case.
There are a number of other use cases.
And I have a quick little demo I'll do in
a minute that shows how that works.
So one of the things in designing this new
API is, we wanted to make sure that we left
developers in control of their own applications.
Now, there are a couple of ways we could have
gone about this.
One is we could enforce it at the system level
and dictate, you know, only one app is ever
going to make audio, be able to generate audio,
and that's it.
And that's not what Android is about.
So we actually made a choice to say, how can
we give applications the information they
need to make good choices about audio and
do innovation?
So that's basically one of the philosophies
while we're designing this.
So, basically, the way it works is, apps and
services can register to receive events about
what's happening with Audio Focus.
They can request Audio Focus.
So the concept of Audio Focus is, my application
needs to be in the foreground of audio.
It's going to be producing something that
the user needs to pay attention to.
An example of that might be the ring tone.
It might be a music player app.
It might be YouTube.
It might be streaming audio.
It might be an e-mail notification.
But for some reason, you want to draw the
user's attention, and that should be the focal
point as far as audio is concerned.
It doesn't necessarily get associated with
the app that's in the foreground.
If I am browsing the Web, it's perfectly fine
for audio to be streaming in the background.
But if there's a Web app that wants to make
a sound, then we need a way to enable that
to take control.
Another kind of unique thing is, if -- the
Audio Focus request can be either a permanent
request, in other words, I want to take over,
or it can be a transient request.
A transient request, a good example of a transient
request is like an e-mail notification.
We're just going to briefly interrupt the
audio and then we're going to come back.
So the app will know -- the background app,
the app that's losing focus will know, hey,
you're temporarily losing it and you're going
to get it back later.
And we've also included something called a
ducking hint.
If you're familiar with -- goes back to the
old radio days when the deejays would talk
over the audio, ducking is reducing the volume
so that you can talk over the top of it.
And so for options that are requesting focus,
they can give a hint to other applications,
hey, it's okay if you go ahead and continue
playing, just reduce your volume.
And the idea there, if you think about the
navigation thing, if music is playing, it's
perfectly fine for that to continue playing.
Just make it a little bit softer so I can
hear the navigation prompt.
And then when the application is done, it
should abandon focus.
It should say, I'm done doing my thing.
You know, send it back to -- send the focuses
back to the previous app.
And then transport controls work in the same
way.
So transport controls, if you've got the wired
headset or you've got a Bluetooth headset
that has next track, previous track type controls,
pause, resume, those controls, we had the
same sort of issues with apps competing over
that.
So the transport controls now follow the sort
of same paradigm of an application can request
them and take over control of it so I don't
have two apps that are competing.
We had situations where somebody would hit
the "play" button, and two applications would
try to start playing at the same time.
So this resolves that issue.
And then what we've done is, we have helper
classes that will be available that use -- using
Reflection, will enable you to put this in
your application and still be backwards-compatible.
So you can write an app that's compatible
with Donut and take advantage of these new
APIs that are in Froyo.
So I'm going to show you a little bit of code
here.
Not too much.
It's pretty simple.
So in your -- this particular sample is really
aimed at a service.
So this would be a music application or a
podcast or something that's playing in background.
If you're doing an app that's playing in foreground,
you probably use -- put your hooks in different
places.
You put it in the on resume and on pause instead.
But in this case, we're going to do it in
on create and on destroy, because it's a service.
So in on create, we get a reference to the
audio manager.
We're also going to tell it in this particular
case that the streams we're outputting are
stream music type.
This basically tells the system how the volume
control should behave when that app is in
the foreground.
So the audio -- the volume controls will get
routed to the music stream instead of a ring
tone or something else.
The next thing is, so I've -- I kind of have
an abstract concept.
So when the application starts playing, you
set this flag playing as true, and you start
your thing.
And then at the very top of it, you can see
"requesting audio focus."
So that tells the system, this application
is now, you know, moving to the foreground
in audio.
And then when the stream stops playing, you
are going to set the playing flag to false.
And if we're not going to restart afterwards,
we're going to change the -- basically, abandon
Audio Focus, so we're going to lose focus.
So this is a case where the user has deliberately
said, "I'm done with this application.
I'm going to stop playing."
We'll see how that restart flag works in the
next page of code.
And then ondestroy, we always abandons focus.
So this takes your application out of the
Audio Focus stack.
So in the next slide, this is kind of where
the root of things happen with the system.
So there's this new interface called OnAudioFocusChangeListener.
So we're creating a new on Audio Focus listener
-- OnAudioFocusChangeListener.
That's a long thing to say.
And it has a public method on Audio Focus
change.
So you'll get a call anytime Audio Focus changes
to your application, it's either going away
or it's coming back to you.
So you can see here we're going to switch
on what event took place.
And in the top -- the first part here, it
says Audio Focus loss.
So we're losing Audio Focus.
So at that point, we're going to -- we're
losing Audio Focus, and we're losing it permanently.
In other words, some other application has
said, "I'm taking over audio now."
And so in this case, we set our restart flag
to false.
Restart flag tells us whether we're going
to restart later on.
Since we're losing it permanently, there's
no point in restarting.
The only way that's going to happen is if
the user actually goes back and says, "I want
to start this application again."
In the case where it's a transient loss, we're
going to treat both transient and transient
can duck the same.
And I'll show you how you can do the ten duck
a little bit later.
So we set our restart flag to true.
That means we've lost focus temporarily, we're
going to get it back.
When we get it back, we want to start playing
again.
And then we just pause the audio stream.
And then in this last case here, when we get
the focus back, if we're not playing and the
restart flag is set, we're going to go ahead
and resume playing and set the restart to
false.
So now we've got Audio Focus back.
And this is how you resume back when whatever
else was going on has finished, you get focus
back and you start playing again.
So an example of this would be let's say an
e-mail notification comes in and it wants
to play the little whatever you've chosen
for your notification tone.
You're first going to get Audio Focus transient.
And that will tell you that you've lost focus
temporarily.
Then you'll get Audio Focus gain.
And that's when you restart your app.
So Audio Focus transient, stop playing.
Audio Focus gain, start playing.
So it's pretty easy to implement this.
The nice thing about this is that once you've
implemented this, the old tricks you might
have used earlier to, like, look at the call
state, am I -- like, the music app used to
do this, where it would look and say, is -- if
the phone is ringing, then I'm going to resume
afterwards.
You don't have to worry about that anymore.
This API will handle all of that.
So it's just one simple set of code you have
to worry about.
And then this next bit of code shows how you
might handle ducking.
So in a case where -- for a podcast type of
application, you probably don't want to duck.
It doesn't make sense to have, you know, the
audio talking, you know, from a podcast go
over some other prompt.
But if it's a music application, streaming
music or some music player, it's probably
okay to have that continue playing in the
background.
So in this case, where all the code for transient
loss is the same as before but for the "can
duck" case, we have a slightly different set
of code here.
So in this case, I'm setting a flag in ducking
that says I'm ducking my volume temporarily
to true, I save the old volume, and I set
my volume to the new volume.
And the new volume in this case is whatever
that is, an eighth, it's, like, down 18 dB.
And so now I've reduced the volume of my output
track while whatever it is is playing, continues
to play.
And when I get focus back, if I was ducking,
the first part of this clause is the same
as before.
The second part of the clause is, if I ducked,
then I'm just going to restore the old volume.
So this is where you can, in your application,
do something slightly different, maybe a better
experience for the user.
Your choice, though.
Then we have soundpool improvements.
Sorry. That was a kind of quick transition
there.
We'll have sample code for this, by the way,
in -- when we release the SDK or on -- probably
a blog entry coming up soon.
And it will include the Reflection code, probably
some sample code on how a service might work.
So going back to soundpool, a couple of things
we got asked about in soundpool.
One of the problems people run into is, the
loading of sounds is asynchronous.
And they wanted a way to know when a sound
was loaded.
So we added new callbacks for once a sound
is loaded, you get a call back that tells
you what sound got loaded.
So now you have a way of knowing when the
sounds are all loaded.
Another big request, because soundpool keeps
track of all the state of different voices,
you don't have a lot of visibility and what's
going on.
If you're pausing the application, you don't
know which streams to pause.
We added an API for automatically pausing
all the streams that are currently playing,
and then the next bit is auto resuming all
the streams that are playing.
So soundpool is a little more friendly in
that respect when you're -- you don't have
to keep track of all the streams that are
playing.
Talked about audio routing improvements.
We have a -- the stream voice call is now
routed to ear piece by default.
Previously, I think it went to speaker.
So if you have an application where you want
to output to the ear piece, a good example
is a voice mail application.
Users have an expectation of privacy in that
case.
You don't want your voice mail necessarily
blasting, you know, if your girlfriend is
calling with some maybe not safe for work
message, you don't want that to go out on
the speaker.
In this case, you can have it routed to the
ear piece by default.
And then you can call set speaker on to route
it to the speaker if they want to.
So a voice mail app, you probably have a speaker
button to route it to the speaker.
Another big request we've had is routing audio
to the Bluetooth SCO device.
So SCO is the eight-kilohertz synchronous
link that is used for in-call audio.
It's a low-quality audio stream, but it's
ubiquitous.
Every Bluetooth headset supports it.
A2DP is the high-quality stereo streams.
There are a lot of devices that don't support
that, so there was a request to be able to
support Bluetooth SCO output.
So now you can do that.
You call start Bluetooth SCO, open your voice
stream, stream voice call, and that will get
it routed out to the SCO output.
Again, useful for voice mail applications
or other applications where you're just going
to send out low-quality audio.
Again, privacy issues.
Camera improvements.
We have a new preview API if you want to do
signal processing on preview frames.
It allows you to -- whoops.
Go back.
It allows you to avoid GCs.
The old way, we would allocate a buffer, copy
the data into it, and then you would end up
with a GC every time you stopped using those.
In this one, you can preallocate your buffers.
You send them down, you in-queue them to the
native code, and it fills the buffer and returns
it to you, and there's no GC.
So we actually found that it doubled the frame
rate for Goggles' application, for example.
And, let's see, there's also an API for compressing
YUV frames from the preview to JPEG.
So if you're trying to do, like, a webcam
type application, you can take the preview
frames, encode them as JPEG, and then ship
them off over Wi-Fi.
We're actually getting, on Nexus One, I think
about ten frames per second over a Wi-Fi connection.
So it's pretty decent.
There's a new no-thumbnail mode for the JPEG
encoder.
Previously, we automatically generated a thumbnail.
If you're doing really small JPEGs and it
doesn't make any sense, so there's a way to
tell it you don't want the thumbnail generated
and reduce the size of the JPEG.
Camera also reports field of view and focal
length parameters in XF.
So now you can get that data back. for AR
applications and things like that, it's -- can
be pretty useful, you know, determining what
the field is you're looking at and using it
for signal processing.
And then we added exposure control settings
so you can, you know, go plus one, plus two,
minus one, minus two on your exposures.
And then, finally, we added portrait mode
support.
We kind of had a hack-in for some devices
previously that I know a few developers out
there figured out.
It was never intended to be supported.
We now have an official way of supporting
it.
I'm going to skip this, 'cause we're trying
to catch up.
And I'm going to talk about road map really
briefly, and then we'll go on to Q&A.
So in the next release, we're planning to
introduce an OpenSL ES API.
It's -- OpenSL ES is a huge surface.
We're going to start small and build up from
there.
But the intention is to expose a native audio
API and OpenSL ES will be the abstraction
layer for that.
That means basically all the audio track stuff
in native code will get converted to an SL
ES layer.
We actually have bits of that code up and
running now.
We're going to add OpenAL support, OpenAL
as a shim over the OpenSL ES.
So, basically, for those of you who are writing
applications that use AL on other platforms,
it should make it a little easier to port
your games, or other applications, for that
matter.
We're adding -- as part of the OpenSL ES,
we're going to add the effects processing
stuff, so that allows you to put in equalizers
or things like that.
We're also going to start exposing some of
the low-level media APIs.
Specifically, what we're going to do is have
a Java API that allows you to build the player
graph dynamically in your application.
In particular, if you have a streaming format
that we don't support, maybe you've invented
the best RTSP protocol in the world and you
want to do some extension or something like
that, one of the problems has been that you
couldn't get access to the codecs, and, you
know, it was really hard to do that.
So this will actually allow you to build the
graph in your code.
And then, again, using something similar to
the techniques we talked about with audio
track, if you want to do native processing
where you do something to the frames or whatever,
you'll be able to get access to it through
native code.
Yesterday, we announced VP8 open source to
the world.
We're saying now that we're going to -- I
think I found another mike down there -- we're
going to support it in the next Android release.
Unfortunately, the bit stream specifics were
a little too late for the Froyo release.
But we have it up and running in our next
release, and so it includes VP8 support, Vorbis
support, and WebM, which is our Metroska-specific
support for VP8 and Vorbis.
We're going to add a FLAC decoder.
We are going to add AAC-LC encoder, software
encoder, for the devices that don't have hardware
support already.
And we're going to add an AMR wide-band encoder.
Those will both be open sourced codecs, so
all the code would be available.
Obviously, there are still licensing issues.
There are patents that you have to license
if you have a device.
But the code will be open.
And now we're going to move on to Q&A.
I'll bring up the slide again if you want
to follow in Wave.
So anybody want to come up to the microphone?
>>> Hello.
Now, one question I had is when to release
the media player.
Because in Android, there's no concept of
exiting an application.
So if a user pauses playback, how do you know
that they won't -- is that the time to release
the media?
How do you know that they won't necessarily
want to start playing a second later?
>>David Sparks: So I didn't quite understand
the question.
Could you try again.
>>> I don't quite understand when I should
be calling -- when I should be releasing -- when
I should call release on media player.
Because if you -- because you don't necessarily
know when the user is kind of done with your
application.
For example, if they just pause it --
>>David Sparks: Oh, oh, okay.
So, yeah, right.
So if they're just pausing it, I think you
probably need to make some intelligent choice,
like maybe you send yourself a delayed message
at five seconds.
And if they haven't restarted in five seconds,
then you tear it down.
A good example, so let's say you wanted to
resume playing where you were.
You get the current play position, and you
save that off, you know, recreate the media
player, and seek to that position and start
playing again.
But I wouldn't go too much longer than that,
because, you know, you leave that thing up,
the DSP, even if it's not doing anything,
is still consuming energy.
>>> Thank you.
>>David Sparks: Uh-huh.
>>> Does your Audio Focus API have any support
for conflicts between recording and playback
or two different recording devices trying
to record at the same time?
>>David Sparks: Two different recording -- So
the question -- the question was, is there
a conflict between recording and playback?
>>> Yes.
That's part of it.
Recording and playback, or two different recording
apps.
>>David Sparks: Okay.
So we don't have a concept of two different
recording inputs yet.
I think there's -- if I'm not mistaken, there's
a source in the audio track -- or audio record
interface.
So you could potentially have more than one.
There's no reason I could think of where -- that
we couldn't support multiple inputs at the
same time.
You know, conceptually, underneath, it would
just mean record -- a new -- there's a record
thread in the media server that would need
to be duplicated for multiple inputs.
But there's no reason from a platform perspective
we couldn't do that.
And as far as recording and playback at the
same time, that should work.
The issue you have with recording, if you're
playing something on the device, you probably
have some leakage from the speaker back to
the microphone, for example, and we don't
have any way to use the acoustic echo cancellation
algorithms that are typically built into the
baseband.
So you have to do that yourself.
>>> Yeah, I was more interested in preventing
it than allowing it.
>>David Sparks: Yeah, there's no way to prevent
it.
>>> Okay.
We have a media streaming application that
we're working on that has content behind authenticated,
you know, protection SSO.
And we had a little bit of difficulty because
the media player allows you to supply a progressive
playback URL, but there's no way to manipulate
the cookie collection or anything with that.
>>David Sparks: Right.
>>> Are there any changes in that area?
>>David Sparks: There's -- I know that there
is a feature request in.
I'm not sure -- hopefully, we'll get to that
in the next release, but it's definitely not
in Froyo.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>David Sparks: That's a good one.
And that's definitely something we want to
deal with.
By the way, just some people have dealt with
that by having a proxy server on the device
that does that.
>>> Dave, do you have any plans for bookmarking?
Right now, applications don't know when a
particular part of the audio stream has actually
reached the codec.
So if you're giving directions, for example,
you don't know where you are in that stream.
>>David Sparks: So basically you want to know
what the latency is through the playback path?
>>> Correct.
And if it gets paused, that you can actually
find out that it was paused and that it hasn't
reached it yet.
>>David Sparks: Right.
So there's -- there's no provisions for that
yet.
I think we get that through the OpenSL ES
interface, if I'm not mistaken.
That drives the latency all the way back.
So you should be able to get that information
when we get to there.
Audio track doesn't do that now.
And there are some challenges with that.
If you look at Bluetooth, for example, we
have no idea how much audio is actually getting
buffered in the Bluetooth device.
It can be, you know, hundreds of milliseconds.
So it's somewhat, you know, nebulous what
that actually means.
The ondevice we should be able to get a better
enough.
>>> I have two questions.
Do we support track-level volume control?
I know that in Android, we have different
streams, and each stream has volume.
Can I have two applications playing the same
music streams, but can I have two different
volumes for two different tracks?
Is that supported today?
>>David Sparks: Well, yeah.
So each -- each audio track has a volume control.
And the media player is built on top of audio
track.
So it has a separate volume control.
And there is a -- if I'm not mistaken, there's
a set volume interface on the media player.
So you can actually set the individual volume
for each media player, as well as each audio
track.
>>> Okay.
The next question is, can I route -- I know
routing is -- something is taken care of by
the framework.
Is there any plan of giving control to the
application to say that, hey, track one broken,
fix it; track two open to speaker? Is there
some kind of call to --
>>David Sparks: So, yeah, the question is,
can you change routing for specific tracks.
A lot of the devices that we deal with don't
actually allow for that.
We're seeing new devices that have sophisticated
mixers down typically in the baseband or DSP
or something like that that have these fancy
routing matrices.
And you -- you know, we should be able to
expose that at some point.
Right now, most of the devices, like, if you
look at the G1 and the myTouch, there's only
one output.
We can route it to SCO, we can route it to
A2DP, we can route it to the speaker, but
we can't do a separate route.
There is a concept in Froyo of what we're
calling a direct output.
And we're using that for some things like
voice dialer now works over SCO.
So we can take that one output and route it.
But there is no mixer for that.
And it may not necessarily be supported in
all devices.
>>> Okay.
>>David Sparks: So it's -- there's a lot of
issues we have to work with on the chipset
and hardware manufacturers.
>>> Last question.
Any support for FM radio?
Because we saw some devices being added --
>>David Sparks: FM radio?
>>> Yeah.
>>David Sparks: We're still working out the
details on that.
We've had a couple of proposals, none that
I was particularly excited about.
But I -- you know, I think we'll probably
come up with something.
-- one of the things -- a lot of stuff we
do is device-driven, product-driven in the
sense that we're working on something, we
kind of think about what we want on that,
until we actually have one that has an FM
radio we're exposing as a feature -- it's
not highly prioritized.
But hopefully in maybe the next year.
>>> Yes, messing around with the ring tone
picker, I noticed that there was a parameter
there for DRM available.
I wonder is this open to developers to use,
and how would we use this?
>>David Sparks: The ring tone picker, what
was the --
>>> I noticed that there was DRM support.
I was wondering how we would access this.
>>David Sparks: Oh, yeah.
My advice is, stay away from the DRM stuff.
We -- we had this forward lock stuff that
we did for our first device.
It's not really well-integrated into the system.
So I didn't get into all the road map stuff.
But we are working on a DRM integration for
the next release.
And it should be easier to do what you want
to do, I think, at that point.
>>> Okay.
>>David Sparks: But the stuff that's there
now is not well supported.
>>> All right.
Thanks.
>>David Sparks: Unfortunately.
Sorry about that.
>>> There have been discussions on Google
Groups that you will be bringing in Stagefright
and replacing that with packet radio OpenCORE.
So can you tell us, is that true?
Or -- and what does the highlights of Stagefright?
>>David Sparks: The question is Stagefright
versus OpenCORE, probably versus G streamer
versus who knows, whatever media framework
might be out there.
We -- so we started Stagefright as, really,
the vehicle for supporting Flash.
It was intended to be a lightweight framework
that allowed us to do, essentially, what I
was talking about earlier, expose the stack
so that you can send elementary streams down
to the codecs and the framework would handle
all of -- AV sync and all that stuff.
So as we got further into that, we said, oh,
if we just -- we'll add a stream extractor,
we'll at this and that.
Next thing you know, we had a media framework.
We kind of accidentally fell into it.
We've been talking to PacketVideo, and they're
going to be cooperating with us on Stagefright.
So in the long run, we're going to move away
from OpenCORE.
We hope to do that in the next release.
For Froyo, it's kind of a mixed bag.
We have Stagefright for local file playback,
and for HTTP progressive.
OpenCORE is still providing the authoring
side and RTSP stack.
So the next piece is to move those over and
expose some of these APIs.
For our hardware integrator, there's a little
bit of extra support, because you basically
have to take your OpenMAX codecs and put them
into both frameworks.
But we think that's not too painful.
And that will be one release.
And then next release, it will all be in Stagefright.
That said, if somebody decided they wanted
to go with OpenCORE or they want to go with
GStream or they want to go with whatever,
we're supportive of that.
The requirement is that you pass the CTS tests.
And CTS will include whatever new APIs we
invent on top of Stagefright.
And I think that's going to kind of force
people to head to Stagefright, although I
wouldn't preclude somebody taking GStream
or making it work.
Did that answer your question?
>>> So could you say the difference again
between the use cases when OpenCORE is going
to be used in Froyo and when Stagefright is
going to be called to Froyo?
>>David Sparks: So OpenCORE will be used for
RTSP and authoring.
So the media recorder is Stagefright.
If you have an RTSP URL, that's -- sorry,
that's OpenCORE.
RTSP, also OpenCORE.
Everything else is Stagefright.
>>> So somebody who's integrating a new codec
will have to have a version integrated with
OpenCORE as well as Stagefright?
>>David Sparks: Yeah, if you're using OpenMAX,
it's really just a matter of dropping it into
the -- the tables for the two frameworks.
>>> And do you have any documentation available
as to -- about Stagefright?
>>David Sparks: It's forthcoming.
When we put the source code out, we'll have
that information as well.
I can take one more question.
>>> I was wondering if you could comment on
how -- how Android right now or in the future
is going to handle with multiple audio streams
or channels, like, surround sound, what with
Google TV and devices with many HTML and things
like that.
>>David Sparks: So open OpenSL ES has a lot
of the answers to that.
There's already provisions to that.
We're still thinking about how the surround
stuff works.
Google TV I think is farther ahead.
Even though it's -- they are both based on
Android, the actual trees are separate at
this point.
We're going to merge them later.
So they're probably better equipped to answer
that question right now.
But, you know, we should -- we'll have -- I
would imagine by the end of next year we'll
probably have some kind of solution for that.
>>> All right.
Thanks.
>>David Sparks: All right.
Thanks, everybody.
[ Applause ]